You're obviously famous for having a very good voice.
But Morgan Freeman is in this.
Now that's the voice of God, baby.
In this changing world.
It's harder than ever to find something extraordinary.
My voice ain't like that.
One thing I can tell you.
If you're looking to improve the sound of your voice, yawn a lot.
Yawn a lot?
Yawn a lot.
Why?
Tell me why.
It relaxes your throat muscles.
It relaxes your vocal cords.
And as soon as they relax, the tone drops.
The lower your voice is, the better your sound.
So if I yawned a lot, I might start sounding like Morgan Freeman.
No, but you would certainly get a deeper voice.
But every once in a while, a symbol of hope breaks through.
Were you annoyed that he got the trailer voice-over?
Man, look, I mean, I've done voice-over work.
It's Morgan Freeman, man.
What are you gonna do?
You know, like, take it bro.
I can't compete with that.
Do you ever talk just to hear the sound of your own voice?
If you're talking just to hear the sound of your own voice, you don't have anything really to say.
Have you got a Morgan Freeman impression?
If you see Harry, ask him because he's got a really good one.
No, I don't.
I would try to but it's terrible.
I would always go, "Be soft," like that.
It's terrible.